[Music]
alright moving on to overwatch I
originally wrote down insurrection but
apparently it has since been called
uprising I think insurrection was a
French one yeah that's I feel like that
it was translated yes uprising so it is
the next update to overwatch Blizzard
have been pretty great about doing these
community events between dr. Junkins
scenes last for halloween they did the
Olympics one before that they did a the
chinese new year they did a holiday one
that you sent you to get more skins new
game modes with a maze snowball fight
that's essentially what it wasn't forget
was actually called but now we have
uprising and it is in terms of story
which you know or watch is pretty light
on story but it's still really good
about adding these morsels in like all
over the place to flush out this great
world and this one is a prequel
apparently tracers first mission humans
vs. robots at seven years before modern
overwatch story yeah yeah I'd say over
watches figure on lower than it is
actually riotous but um and yes this is
definitely just kind of building out
tracers origin more she has kind of
their poster child so right she's it's
more of a doctor junking junkins gains
or junk it's time I would same scene
drunken seen bait no sign junk on a
daily base make your insane grinstein
bears uh but yeah it's more of a horde
mode for cooperative horde mode and then
of course there would be skins victory
poses or be all kinds of you know just
new aesthetic stuff as over watches want
to do with move boxes and whatnot
quickly before I get into this next part
of the segment which I'm excited about
Michael do you plan do you still
constantly play overwatch so Oh with
multiplayer games I've noticed as I've
gotten older that I jump in and out of
them and I have phases so what an
overwatch first drop I play that for
like a month straight okay then I waited
like three months and then I jumped on
it again for another month period and
then I when I came here is like okay now
I'll jump into it again but the thing is
that whenever you add extra game modes
I'm always intrigued by that like I'm
down to play new modes and keep things
fresh because as great as the base game
is that you know having extra stuff on
the side
to do kind of adds to how much I love a
game overall so having the sword more
like when halo came out with their hoard
type of mode like that was dope assalam
and firefight in ODST yeah so that was
sweet and you know Gears of War when
they had their hoard mode I was like wow
generator yeah yeah we do have Joey here
in our studio this isn't playing right
now is Reinhardt uh yeah there we go
there you got a keyboard so yeah Joey's
going to be playing while we talk about
overwatch new update but yeah he's uh
he's playing Reinhardt I would ask him
questions about overwatch but he doesn't
like no I don't I don't know how often
he plays Ryan hard but this right here
is the uprising is that horde mode I was
just mentioning here on the London map
kings row so yeah it's about you like
I'm Nick uprising back in the day before
/ watches modern timeline as it were
Kelly do you play much overwatch or you
yeah I'm not getting back into it with
this yeah like Michael I I do the face
of thing so when it first came out I was
playing every single night and then I
had enough people playing that like we'd
always have someone to swap in when
someone had to leave like it was yeah we
were playing constantly and then I sort
of dropped off from it and I've been
really wanting to go back especially
because I haven't played like sombra or
anything yet and that October awesome
I'm a I'm a mercy main though and I'm
very loyal to her and that intrigues me
about this mode since mode is a
Reinhardt torbjörn mercy and tracer if
you don't play the all heroes version so
I'm just always excited to have a reason
to play mercy yeah these updates are
perfect for bringing me back in they're
great for rewarding loyal players and
overwatch is always good about that I
mean even if you're like a hero the
storm player their / they're adding
Genji to it soon right there they
updated they've been updating for years
but overwatch these are great for pull
me back in when I'm a snowball fight
again I might be butchering that name
when that came back out i got back into
it for the skins i got i'm a zaria main
zara and ahna i think i actually been
liking autumn more but uh I just need
some more Hussein who's in the chat to
know that I'm better with zari than he
is
yeah this biz mode looks fun I didn't
actually play a lot of the junk ensigns
horde mode because there's only four I
didn't I thought maybe they would let
you select any character you want but it
was only four it was like Makri mercy I
think it was ryan hart and i forget the
last characters but yeah this is more
based around tracers story I think it's
her first mission with overwatch before
it kind of dissipated and then obviously
Winston brought them back together later
on according to the lore but Joey doing
pretty well I can't respond we can hear
oh yeah but yes so this is live on this
is live right now so you can go play
this if you want to but yeah this is the
horde mode of course tons of loot boxes
and get you new skins and aesthetics and
whatnot the Moors in the YouTube
checking feeling right now wow I'm still
bummed i don't have mercies which oh
yeah that one was really good man
speaking of tomorrow saying one thing we
wanted to highlight this show tour was
saying for those who don't know he's our
UK editor but he's also a very gifted
interviewer who it was hirata he
interviewed right the first time we kind
of were like wow tomorrow might be kind
of probably yeah yeah that sounds all
right oh yeah oh no oh yeah you should
know your oh noes from Capcom okay and
so it's more recently didn't interview
Jeff Kaplan who has kind of become
dislike pseudo syllable celebrity
because for numerous reasons but he does
all these developer updates for Blizzard
the heat on the overwatch news the
director of overwatch and he's just this
really like affable personable guy if
you don't know who is but also there is
of course this like YouTube channel that
essentially just takes the developer
updates and cuts up the words and makes
new mashups so he's kind of become this
weird kind of halfway celebrity halfway
meme I guess on YouTube but so it's more
sat down to interview him in the UK just
last week a couple weeks ago yeah and so
we wanted to kind of highlight a few
different parts of this interview which
I like to compare to two people walking
hand in hand into the Oblivion so just
into the void yeah together into outer
space to die together so where you have
screenshots the interview I want the
highlight and then I actually have a
gift for tomorrow
the end but yeah jean-luc can you pull
up part of this I'm going to kind of
narrate this interview and kind of walk
you through how crazy was alright so the
bulb section is two more asking
questions and I wanted to show you what
kind of shampoo do you use because your
hair always looks great in the developer
updates Jeff Kaplan oh awesome I don't
even know the name of it it's one for my
wife puts in the shower I'm so terrible
hope question and yeah follow-up
question I added just to show you how
quickly it went back to being
professional I also pulled up an image
that I kind of hastily made to show you
how nice Jeff Kaplan's hair looks indie
developer updates it's just got this
sheet but what if it gets in the wind
like that's what I'm worried about how
does it look like it looks pretty
windswept and boyish to me and I really
like it and how could you know it like
how I wouldn't besides them at all wins
that'sthat's some nuts pro level be like
yes like on the side that's hard that's
hard to keep up either way I wish he
actually told us what shampoo it was
because I would use it uh no do you got
your shop for your own show oh my god uh
alright moving on to the next question
well the next screen shot John Luke
please this interview gets better as it
goes honestly here we go does Winston
like crunchy or smooth peanut butter I
think he likes both I think if left to
his own devices it's smooth but he
wouldn't turn down crunchy either does
Jeff Kaplan like crunchy or smooth
peanut butter I like smooth for sure and
I love peanut butter I'm like Winston
and that if I had one food that I had to
survive off of for the rest of my life
it'd be peanut butter same I once
purchased 10 kilograms of peanut butter
just because it was on discount nice
that's awesome again this is an actual
interview we put we conducted two more
Hussein conducted and we put on g spot
yeah all right John Luke next one please
did you hear the story about the girl
who called another kada Hanzo main I did
yes do you endorse calling people ohon
domain as a way to dunk on them pretty
long response but not as a direct
derogatory way we need to love and
respect all mains including Hanzo main
it's a funny story we actually reached
out to the girl her family we sent them
a note the parents sent back it's lovely
at our letter to us and said we
appreciate it so much that you guys
reach that we've been talking to our
daughter about not making fun of
somebody for maintaining a certain here
I think the whole community learned a
little lesson in there
I actually sent John Luke v.jpg of the
actual like teacher complaint of the kid
insulting yeah I'm sorry what that means
another student we took her pencil and
she referred to him as a Hanzo main I
have no idea of what this means however
is clearly meant as an insult my
embarrassing thing is that i was
actually a home domain for a while yeah
alright next question John Luke please
all right this is fantastic to to the
one from put one to the 30 whats up this
is Jeff from the overwatch team the rest
guy had there so I actually sent John
Luke the youtube link if you haven't
seen it it's got I forget how many views
but this is what this is what sparked it
Dino flask is the youtube channel so
it's like about a minute and a half I
actually thought it'd be worth it to
play in its entirety because it is
fantastic and it highlights exactly why
he's become a meme just so we can sit
back and enjoy this and watch this right
now have you seen this no it's a really
good where that dough over yet where
were you telling us again John Luke
alright it's gonna be a sec you find it
as you remember it can you can you do
scrunchie yeah well two more just go to
to the one from the one to the three
it's really good here we go twenty or
without you I couldn't finish there's no
audio okay well we don't need to watch
it just go to Dino flask of YouTube
channel you can watch that and you get a
sense when you're actually watching it
these get like this has like a million
and a half to use a thing and this is
what kick-started it so when he got
announced when he got introduced on the
what I think maybe it was like the
Bastile words or GDC or something
someone said like a man made famous by
one of the most famous like video game
memes is coming on stage but anyway all
right here's the last part this is where
it got pretty weird and it's also it
highlights to Moore's uh kind of
household and I want to kind of paint
this in a way so next screen shot John
Luke please
oh this is my google you near name this
is the first pics that shows up that is
awesome you should probably do something
about that what can I do if you read so
you've been publicly shamed by Jon
Ronson he meets people that specialize
in varying unwanted search engine
results might be useful oh really no to
be honest I think it's a pretty good
picture and we could pull that town but
yeah I was just corroborating some more
thing and that is true that the first
photo shows up people enjoy screenshot
eng jeff kaplan when he is uh in
compromising photos on developer updates
all right John Luke pull up this next
one the one that gets really weird this
is the one I had mentioned i thought was
up next but here we go this is some more
talking about his cat all right so he
asked about he said there's a rumor
about this cat hero that they ditched
and so Jeff Kaplan said we had done a
lot of concept thing we had one hero who
was just a hockey player literally a
hockey player we made her later made
lucio skin for a hockey player but he
was just a hockey player hero then
there's this one here there's a huge
internal debate on the team because we
just loved it so much but it didn't make
it was this jetpack and I had this cat
that laid in it like a cat does then
every once in a while I would polity
controls it was a cat in a jetpack that
was one of those moments to help define
overwatch we just went yeah that's
probably too far but yes we had a cat
hero and tomorrow being of sound mind
said that sounds incredible you should
bring it back and then I'm gonna go he
has yes I have two cats named Kiki and I
want to really try to explain this as
best as I can he doesn't have to
separate cats each named Kiki you will
just be into more Department look over
and see those two cats and that you'll
call it a collective collectively their
pair of cats is Kiki because they don't
leave each other side a or collectively
named so i was reading that it was funny
but I was really disappointed that they
didn't include that cat hero so as a
gifted tomorrow and Jeff Kaplan I
reached out to Dan our on our design
team he's on designer here and we made
Kiki we made the cat hero Kiki with a
jetpack that is the collective pair of
cats named Kiki with a jetpack just got
a sec play the game I like to think of
it as an offensive character and yeah
that was my gifted two more and Jeff
Kaplan do with it what you will Blizzard
if you want to that is Dan our again
anyway
I'm so happy yeah that was uh that was
that was my redemption for them not
actually making the cat hero so anyway
yeah if you want to read that whole
interview it is on gamespot com it is
even weirder if you read the whole thing
so go do that and go play overwatch all
right thank you John Luke tomorrow
things in our YouTube chat and so my god
I sweet so let us know if you're going
to be going back to or watches uprising
update when what you think of that cat
hero and sign a petition or something to
make it real
[Music]